i
[Música]
a
aquí en donde en el barrio antiguo de
pekín los mayores de 60 años reciben 30
huevos por el primer pinchazo y otros 30
por el segundo es una de las estrategias
para convencer a los reacios en la zinc
el distrito del sur las autoridades han
repartido vales de descuento en los
supermercados por valor de 200 millones
de yuanes unos 30 millones de dólares y
varias heladerías ofrecen un dos por uno
a los vacunados si vamos a chan en el
distrito céntrico al sur de tiannamen
veremos que a las puertas de las
viviendas han colocado unas pegatinas
que indican cuál es el porcentaje de
residentes vacunados esas presiones más
o menos sutiles ejercidas por algunas
empresas y por las unidades vecinales
han provocado que el gobierno tuviera
que recordar en los últimos días que la
vacunación es voluntaria china hace un
mes decidió acelerar el proceso de
vacunación pero paradójicamente su éxito
contra la pandemia juega ahora en su
contra porque muchos chinos no le ven la
utilidad a vacunarse contra un virus que
hace ya un año fue prácticamente
erradicado
el país
[Música]
de cuñas radiales comerciales de
televisión avisos en la prensa medio
en especial para los adultos mayores los
primeros en la línea de vacunas yo
también ha habido una campaña en redes
sociales en especial con las cuentas
gubernamentales
incluyendo la del presidente de manuel
march con algunos ministros como el
encargado de la cartera de salud hizo
público el momento en que recibió la
primera dosis de la vacuna a esto se
suma la creación de un slogan y de un
logo el eslogan a que rezan vacunarse es
protegerse por ahora francia no ha
adoptado como otros países en eeuu suela
el reino unido- de pedir que
personalidades del mundo del espectáculo
se unan a la campaña de vacunación pero
esta nueva estrategia podría cambiar
porque según un reciente sondeo
solamente el 50 por ciento de los
franceses entre los 18 y los 34 años
estaría dispuesto a vacunarse contra él
con 19
[Música]
el promedio cerca de 3 millones de
vacunas al día son puestas a
disponibilidad del público en eeuu en
total el gobierno de iovine ha
distribuido casi 280 millones de vacunas
en todo el país sin embargo solo cerca
del 40% de la población está vacunada y
se necesita más del 80% para lograr la
inmunidad de rebaño para hacer frente a
este reto el gobierno federal sigue
incrementando el número de vacunas
disponibles en las zonas del país mas
marginalizadas ha creado centros de
vacunación móvil ha contratado a más de
100.000 trabajadores públicos y lanzó
una campaña de educación para mejorar la
confianza en la vacuna
[Música]